I can show you an algorithm called
quicksort hopefully this bit of paper
here will be sufficient to do that okay
so again we start with unsorted list
this time we partition the list into two
bits so rather than just fitting into
two bits of equal size we take one
element which we call the pivot it
doesn't really matter which one you pick
I mean actually it does matter a little
bit I which I'll get into in a minute
okay so we pick one call the pivot will
do take the rightmost one okay so we've
got five so put that there so every
element in this list that is less than
or equal to five goes in this side and
every element that's greater than it
goes on this side so seven goes on the
right 8 goes on the right seven goes on
the right four goes on the left three
goes on the left 10 goes on the right so
then we do the same again for these two
sub lists we've got so we take 3 as the
pivot for this one and four is greater
than XO goes on the right so with this
one we take take 10 as the pivot so
everything less goes on the left so it's
actually all the elements and then we
keep breaking these down so we've got
either one element or no elements in
each list so we know they're sorted okay
so we take seven as the pivot eight goes
on the right and seven less than or
equal goes on the left so then we rejoin
these lists flat together so start at
the bottom we take the pivot everything
on the left goes behind it everything on
the right goes on top of it okay so
we've got the pivot here put four on top
of it got 10 here everything I left goes
behind it and then here we've got the
pivot so these go on that's left and
these go on its right okay so now we've
got one sorted list now you do have to
be careful about what you choose ask the
pivots usually what they'll do is you'll
either pick the first element or the
last element because it's just easier
ideally you want to be able split the
lessons about to even parts so really
want the pivot to be the middle most
number but you don't know what that is
at the start so in the average case it's
the same as merge sort we've got n Times
log N and in the best case it's still
a login but in the worst case well let
me show you okay so let's say we've got
a list that's already sorted so I'll
just take the cars we had before if we
always choose a pivot from the rightmost
element we've got ten so tens the pivot
so all the elements left on it go on the
Left we've got all the elements
basically okay so then we pick eight as
the next pivot all the elements go on is
left we pick seven as the next then all
the rest go on the left then pick the
next seven and what you see is we end up
with cards all the way down here and
then we've got to merge them back
together okay
and actually that works out in the worst
case as N squared so again it's the
square of the input size so we've got
the worst case bubble sort is still N
squared and the worst cater merge sort
is it's still n log N
Carr will definitely have been swapped
all the way to the end so actually you
don't need to check that one anymore you
can move that off and you just get these
third-party cookies hello the
advertisers to faker Oh have you seen
this advert before